that piranhas are vicious bloodthirsty
creatures that will tear you apart in
minutes is largely a myth being
president Theodore Roosevelt was on a
survey expedition in Brazil where he
witnessed a group of locals tossing a
dead cow into a river that they had
stalked with starving piranhas The
Feeding Frenzy that followed LED
Roosevelt to see piranhas as the
embodiment of evil ferocity he compared
their teeth and their jaws to those of
sharks and claimed that their preferred
prey is usually much larger than
themselves the real truth is that
piranhas are relatively calm fish and
most of them are scavengers that feed on
insects worms and plant material in the
rivers where they live of the few
species of piranha that are attracted to
the smell of blood well they tend to go
for prey that's roughly the same size as
them